la bière c'est bon pour le moral
ah bah boire une petite bière c'est vrai
que ça détend après le boulot en
terrasse avec les potes bon c'est frais
ça fait du bien c'est une petite
euphorie qui monte on est bien prêt
c'est vrai que ça marche aussi avec
n'importe quel autre boisson sans alcool
et surtout le moment qui est cool c'est
vrai qu'avec la bière il y a la petite
euphorie en plus puis bon si on aime
bien ça bah c'est toujours agréable de
se faire plaisir là on parle d'un truc
modéré pas trop régulier parce que
j'imagine qu'il y en a certains d'entre
vous qui savent très bien ce que c'est
que la déprime d'un lendemain de cuite
et sur le long terme ça peut provoquer
ou aggraver une dépression pour dire les
choses autrement c'est vrai que l'alcool
ça en effet anxiolytique mais ça a pas
d'effet anti-dépresseur c'est même le
contraire alors on dit aussi que ça aide
à mieux dormir donc à se sentir bien
l'alcool ça aide à s'endormir ok mais ça
perturbe les rythmes du sommeil donc on
a un sommeil de mauvaise qualité et au
final on se réveille en moins bonne
forme donc une petite bière ou deux de
temps en temps si on aime ça ça fait
plaisir mais sur le long terme on peut
pas dire que ce soit bon pour le moral
l'alcool ça crée toujours plus de
problèmes que ça n'en résout dans la
mesure où ça n'en résout jamais